we've had some messages from viewers
they're worried why is the periodic
table changing again most people can
understand when you get an element with
a new Lane like Cappin it seemed this
year but these numbers which have been
here for ages under the different
elements the so called atomic weight how
can that change and suddenly they read a
new story a u-pack international union
of pure and applied chemistry has
changed them it's nothing sacred why can
they change these things well the answer
is they haven't really changed them but
what these numbers are are the so called
atomic weights which are the weights of
the average weight of the different
isotopes of the elements isotopes are
atoms that have different weights most
elements have more than one sort of atom
which are chemically the same we've told
you about hydrogen and deuterium these
are just the same lots of elements have
more than one isotope Carbon has two
carbon-12 carbon-13 and a radioactive
one carbon-14 the one that was used to
date the Turin Shroud so what have they
changed what they've changed are these
weights which refer to the average of
the weights of the different isotopes of
the elements what are you pack has
recognized is the fact that different
samples of elements from different
places around the world whether it's
sulfur from a volcano will sulfate from
a mine somewhere in England have
slightly different isotopic compositions
and therefore they have slightly
different atomic weights up till now all
scientists have been trying to fit the
same atomic weight to sulfur from
everywhere and they've gone to all sorts
of snags now what it's been decided is
there's a range of values sulfur on the
earth can have an average weight from
this amount to that one for example here
with boron instead of being ten point
eight one one
can be from ten point eight zero six to
ten point eight to one and they've
changed the things for ten elements this
is just a minor adjustment and it'll
make it so much easier for chemists to
work I have no idea why they've done it
now I think it's probably because
there's been some careful work done by
the US Geological Survey they've
published their results in this paper
who've actually worked out what are the
acceptable values for this range for the
elements and are you pack has adopted it
the question is should you throw away
your periodic table the answer is if
it's on the mug like my tea mug throw it
away because it's disposable anyway but
if you've got a nice one like this one
here on the office wall keep it because
the difference is very small and it's
not going to affect your daily life as a
chemist so why would for example sulfur
from volcano a be different from sulfur
from crystal B why why is sulfur not
consider consistent blend of the
isotopes well when you have isotopes
because of their different mass it gives
chemical bonds a very slightly different
strength and if you start having
different strength chemical bonds the
molecules react at different rates so if
you have a whole series of reactions
that are producing hydrogen sulfide or
natural elemental sulfur there will be
different reactions the different
isotopes will have different rates and
so they wind up in different ratios of
course the overall ratio in the universe
will be fixed it's just it will be
slightly different in one place and
another it doesn't apply to chemists
like me but it will be important to
people for example who is studying
geology looking at the elemental
composition of rocks where they're over
millions of years there has been some
change in the ratio
most chemists they probably won't bother
very much at all because if you want to
measure the mass of atoms or molecules
very accurately you will use a mass
spectrometer which will measure the mass
of the individual isotopes and then the
average atomic weight doesn't really
matter very much at all
so it's something that's interesting
it's fun makes you think about chemistry
again but it's not something that's
going to change our lives enormous ly